Mo-mo-monkaW
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So, da bin ich wieder.
Wachs war safe, Rennen oder Radl fahren?
Ne.
Ich war einfach nur essen.
Da hab ich noch ein paar Quests gemacht.
Jetzt habe ich den Stream wieder angeschmissen.
Rennen muss ich mal gucken.
Ich meine, ich bin gestern meine neun Kilometer gerannt.
Das kann eigentlich schon als...
...Wochenende Long Run halbwegs durchgehen.
Ich meine, es war nur...
...bisschen unter einer Stunde.
Ne, Quatsch. Nicht unter einer Stunde.
Na doch. Doch.
ein bisschen unter einer Stunde war das
war das ganze Jahr
ähm
und
deswegen könnte man sagen
heute ist der Tag wo ich Pause mache
falls ich keinen Bock mehr hab
können wir das
hören ja
zeig mal
Playlist ist immer noch nicht schlecht
müssen wir erstmal den index raus machen, weil es uns wieder rumbuckt.
Oder ne, wir müssen das da raus machen.
ok
excellent
so was für ein distro benutzt du gerade cash ios wir machen jetzt mal folgendes
bevor wir richtig anfangen mit dem stream ich installiere mal cash ios nackig neue
ja perfekt
installiert das mal neu und dann installieren wir dann nackig
ich bin ich bin dumm weil voll von cd starten
War der nicht gecheckt, oder?
Boah, ich war zu lahm
Ey Gott, was backt denn der Scheiß?
Also ganz ehrlich, Leute, vor allem, weil da kriegst du immer Anfälle mittlerweile
Wie beschissen kann man eigentlich eine Software machen?
Von einer halbwegs gut funktionierenden Version zu kompletter Schrott
Introducing, was?
25H2U1
okay zeigt mal ja was hat sich da ist geändert
ja so gut wie nix im endeffekt geil und jetzt sogar je nachdem ich will starten
es packt wieder als parkt für das krieg anfälle
jetzt hat sie doch am falschen start okay okay okay das packt immer so krass rum wir
machen jetzt einfach mal weil ich weiß woran es liegt dass das liegt hier dran
warum auch immer macht ja überhaupt keinen sinn
wir starten jetzt von cd da müssen wir uns erst mal wieder genau weil bevor wir anfangen
können mal installiert mir mein magisches magisches cash ios die weiteren wochenende geht so
ich habe morgen auch noch frei was sehr nice war war die rufbereitschaft letztes wochenende
es war nichts und es waren feiertage und ich hatte 24 724 24 24 ich hatte von donnerstag
bis dienstag morgen auf bereitschaft es gibt noch mal hätte stonks money diesen
monat wobei nicht zwangsläufig diesen monat dann wenn ich es abrechnen
jetzt kann man eigentlich hier rausgehen und sagen jetzt sagt display accelerate
3D-Graphics.
Launch Installer.
So, kann man
CacheOS nackig installieren?
Ohne Desktop-Umgebung.
Weil ich will es komplett nackig ohne Desktop-Umgebung
haben.
American English.
Wir können auch
British English.
Berlin.
German.
Ja, ist mir...
Ne, wir machen Crap. Das andere backt immer rum.
Erased Disk.
32 Gig ist ein bisschen wenig, aber für unsere Zwecke reicht das.
BTFS, sehr gute Idee.
Plasma. No Desktop kann man machen.
Exquisite.
War stressig das Woche?
Nein, nein, nein.
No Desktop.
Kein Deskop.
Mein Vater hat Desktop immer Deskop ausgesprochen früher.
Warum auch immer.
Ich glaube, der hat einfach nicht gecheckt, was Desktop sein soll.
Deskop.
der hat immer gesagt ich mach mir ich mach mir das icon auf der scope
es ist die musik ein bisschen laut
der scope sowie scope
was genau macht das fisch eigentlich auf dem hähnchen da okay es ist jetzt nur
der skope next user max omega hecke 123456 einfach 6 next install install soll mal gucken ob ich
irgendwie ein snapshot habe weil den müssen wir rückgängig machen sonst brauchst du viel
festplatten platz und mir kackt schon wieder ab
wo warst du daheim
ja anscheinend das was ich gerade ausgewählt habe also ohne desktop ich
muss man weil ich gerade eine sache radelfahrer ich müsste unbedingt mal
mein fahrrad sauber machen und neuen kettenwachs drauf machen
damit ich damit ich mir ordentlich fahren kann und ein bisschen auf die
pedale zum rein klipsen und quietschen die linke da hat einer nicht richtig probe gelesen
wie bewachst du deine kette ich habe noch kein heißwachs gerät aber ich bin da überlegen wenn
ein heißwachs gerät zu kaufen ist das nicht voll der aufstattung ich hab's ich habe so eine so eine
eine kleine flasche mit wachs drin und das tröpfelt man dann einfach drauf treten paar
mal lässt einmal im kreis das kopf ist überall drauf lässt ein paar mal durch drehen und dann
ist gut neben dem fahrrad ist das mittlerweile relativ standard sogar die profis fahren gewachs
ketten das ist so du hast einfach so ein kleines fläschchen das einzige was du machen musst ist
du musst die kette einmal vorher initial richtig sauber machen darf keinerlei fett mehr dran sein
deswegen ist am besten man kauft sich eine neue kette die neuen ketten sind kommen aber vor
gefettet oftmals die muss man dann erstmal ordentlich reinigen gibt es aber auch passende
flüssigkeit für das wirklich gar kein fett mehr dran ist so und dann die richtig die richtig gut
ausgestatteten leute haben so ein heißwachs gerät das ist im endeffekt so
eine kochplatte mit einem wachs dings wurde rein preisen kann so ein
heißwachsgerät wurde an die kette reinmacht danach hängst du ein bisschen
auf habe ich aber nicht bin ich überlegen zu kaufen
ich habe so eine flasche mit so trip trip on wachs ist überhaupt kein akt
und das schöne ist das schöne ist dass das danach viel besser in der handhabung
ist weil bei öl und irgendwelchen fett und kram auf der kette oder beziehungsweise im ganzen antrieb
beim fahrrad das sammelt sich halt auch ganz schnell irgendwelcher dreck drin und klebt da
fest wenn du wenn du sachen mit kettenwachs hast du kannst im prinzip danach ein bisschen
wasser drüber laufen lassen das ist alles wieder sauber weil du halt nicht dieses klebrige vom fett
hast sollte jetzt in die neustadt die schotter und wer hat doch jetzt müssen wir noch die grafik an
man es kommt ein bisschen mehr gramm hier in bergen
ja ich habe cash ist ja schon eine weile auf meinem normalen linux pc heute machen
wir das mal einer vm weil das einfach vom handling her bisschen angenehmer ist aber
man noch nichts darauf eingerichtet hat konflikt kann man darüber kopieren ich habe hier mein mini
pc stehen der hat schon seit ich würde mal sagen so ungefähr zwei drei monaten cash us drauf aber
es ist eigentlich eine gute distro es ist ja es ist ja im endeffekt in arch linux mit ein
bisschen zusätzlichen paketen offiziell supporten paketen und was ja wohl dieser selling point so
von cashy ist dass es halt erstens ein bisschen vor konfiguriert daher kommt und das ist so ein
super performance optimierten ich bin mir nicht so sicher ob das ich bin mir nicht so sicher ob
das geht wenn ich ehrlich bin wenn ich mir das gerade so angucke ich habe da meine zweifel dass
dass das funktioniert.
Ich will nicht, dass es lädt.
Wenn es lädt, dann stürzt es ab.
Wie war das?
Guck, ich habe jetzt einfach nochmal neu gestartet.
In der Hoffnung, jetzt funktioniert es.
Ach so,
Chad, ich bin ja auch dumm.
Ich hab doch ohne Desktop installiert.
Das kann ja gar nicht starten,
irgendwo hin.
Aber ich dachte, dann komme ich wenigstens
auf eine Shell oder sowas.
Okay, Chat, wir brechen mal kurz ab.
Machen das hier wieder raus.
Kann man Cache nicht ohne Shell installieren?
Äh, nee, nicht ohne Shell.
Blödsinn, ohne Desktop.
Da hängt doch irgendwas.
Da ist doch irgendwas broken.
Da ist doch irgendwas komplett broken gerade.
Ist das kaputt, wenn man Casio installiert?
Ohne...
Ich wollte das eigentlich komplett vom Scratch.
Muss ja gehen da.
Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher.
Das backt halt manchmal rum.
Okay.
aber noch mal aus hätte das noch mal connect
dann noch mal cd
ein ause hat ja weil ich will es ja wirklich rom from scratch einrichten
auch da auch kein login manager oder irgendwie sowas ich log mich dann
einfach ein gibt mir ein oder wie man das genau startet keine ahnung chat wenn
das ding rumspackt dann installiere ich mir das einfach hier auf normalen arch
linux dann ist halt kein install without desktop install with no desktop
Okay.
If you already installed the system, just uninstall it.
Ja gut, das könnte man theoretisch auch machen.
Wäre anständig einfach.
Ja, aber Cache hat ein paar mehr offiziell supportete Pakete dabei,
die die halt maintainen.
Was für Niri und so ganz gut ist,
weil ich mir nicht mal sicher bin,
wir können mal das vergleichen,
bin mir gar nicht sicher,
ob Niri überhaupt standardmäßig mit dabei ist bei Arch Linux
oder ob man das nur über einen hour package kriegt.
Schauen wir mal.
Next, next, german, machen wir das gleiche nochmal was wir eben gemacht haben.
Group, erase, no desktop.
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Ich glaube
Ja, das soll meinetwegen so heißen
Das ist auch gut
Ich glaube, das ist verbuggt, wenn man
CacheUS installiert
Ohne Desktop Environment
Gucken wir mal hier
Was das sagt
Ich muss hier erstmal ein Update
Vom System machen
weil ich hatte die vm wahrscheinlich schon jetzt einen monat oder so nicht mehr an weil ich ja
eigentlich auf dem mini pc unterwegs bin ich will es aber eigentlich nicht in der vm machen
sag ich ganz ehrlich da ist ja schon so viel zeug vorinstalliert ich wollte es mal from scratch
einrichten weil ich nicht die vorkonfigurierten sachen haben will das war zumindest der plan
Ich will das komplett selbst einrichten, ohne vorkonfigurierten Kram.
Weil wenn du das einrichtest...
Ich meine, klar, ich kann auch einfach installieren, CacheOS und dann mein Heimatverzeichnis, die Configs löschen oder so.
Ja, das geht auch.
Aber ich wollte es halt mal komplett ohne was installieren, ohne alles.
8 GB Update.
Ja, hier.
ArchLinux.
Da machst du nix.
Ich glaube, jetzt checkt das.
Wenn du das ein paar Wochen nicht anhast,
kannst du froh sein, dass es nur
8,5 Gigs sind. Nur.
Wie groß? Chat, ich weiß,
das ist komplett random jetzt. Wie groß
ist eigentlich, vielleicht spielt ja einer von euch noch
Warzone. Wie groß ist denn die aktuelle
Warzone-Installation? 250
Gig oder was?
Das war ja vor
ein paar Jahren, wo ich das noch gespielt habe, schon
riesengroß.
Ja, das Problem ist halt Nvidia.
So.
Eins ist halt wirklich...
180 Gig, Alter!
Es ist aber echt schnell, muss man sagen.
Guck mal, Leute.
Das waren jetzt massig Updates.
Jetzt 8,5 Gig und das flutscht wie sonst was.
Das ist halt echt lächerlich für ein Game.
Das ist, wenn die halt keinen Bock haben,
irgendwas nach dem Motto,
warum sollten wir Audio komprimieren?
Wir können es einfach als Waff
speichern und so nach dem Motto.
Ich habe eh den Eindruck, die sind da alle
komplett unfähig.
Wobei ich weiß gar nicht, ob die unfähig sind.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass das halt alles mit
sehr heißer Nadel gestrickt.
So nach dem Motto,
haben wir Zeit, das ordentlich zu machen?
Ne.
Warte mal, es klopft.
So, wieder am Start.
Okay, ich glaub's euch.
Ich glaub's euch. Guck mal.
Der hier schreibt,
der hier schreibt, dass das
299 Gig groß ist.
Warzone, aktuell.
Das ist halt echt
der Witz, Alter. Der Witz.
Finde ich auch zu groß.
Aber immerhin besser als 300 Gig.
Meinst du, das liegt daran, dass man will, dass die Leute nicht gleichzeitig mehrere Games installiert haben können?
Ich finde, das ist eine plausible Erklärung.
Die habe ich jetzt noch nicht gehört, aber das passt zum Corporate Mindset.
Restart now. Finish. Done.
So, mal gucken, ob
Cash.us das jetzt gebutton kriegt.
Boss Champ?
Okay, ich glaube, Cash.us kriegt das nicht gebutton.
Das ist kaputt, wenn du keinen Desktop installierst.
Das kann sich dir in der Ernst sein.
Oder, oder, oder, oder, was auch sein kann, wir lassen das mal kurz.
Es kann auch sein, dass der erste Start ein bisschen braucht.
Warum auch immer, kann man vielleicht die...
Ich habe gerade versucht, die Textkonsole durchzuschalten.
Aber Alter, wie das rumbackt.
So wirklich machen tut das ja nix jetzt, ne?
Das macht doch hier unten auf der Platte nichts mehr.
Ein wenig broken ist es ja schon.
Aber was witzig ist,
Ctrl-Alt-Delete funktioniert noch.
Das muss man jetzt nicht wirklich nachvollziehen, oder?
So, wie sieht es hier eigentlich aus?
Niri, gibt es das?
What the fuck?
Was ist denn das?
Was habe ich denn da gerade ausgeführt?
Ruby API
Reference Frontend.
Okay.
Ruby mein Page. Das wollte ich gleich ausführen.
Ich wollte Niri suchen.
Okay, Niri gibt's
hier.
Ich will eigentlich eine neue Installation haben.
Ach, jetzt geht's.
Wir müssen einfach nur warten, Leute.
Wir müssen einfach nur warten.
Dann easy.
Ja, da sind wir.
Cashios.
So, das ist jetzt Fisch.
Fisch wollen wir nicht haben.
Wir machen jetzt als erstes mal einen Pac-Man.
Dass es am aktuellsten ist.
So, dann sagen wir Pac-Man.
Wir wollen Yay installieren.
Judo.
Weil bester Package Manager.
Weiß nicht, placing the fast written in Rust.
Okay, scrollable, das da ist es.
Das installieren wir jetzt.
Was müssen wir jetzt installieren?
21 providers available for xtg desktop portal impel was was willst du von mir
xtg desktop portal cosmic xtg desktop portal dde
was
Okay, ich hab legit keine Ahnung, was das von mir will
Arch, Niri, wir machen jetzt einfach mal hier
Gucken uns das an, was das Arch-Wiki dazu sagt
Nimm die Vault, Cosmic?
Ne, das glaub ich nicht, dass wir Cosmic wollen
Aha
G-XDG Desktop Portal GTK
G-XDG Desktop Portal Gnome
Wisst ihr was ich mache?
Ich installe die Desktop Portal KDE
Falls es das gibt
Plasma
Gibt es das irgendwo?
6 ich weiß nicht was das ist ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung was ist die die arch
die pin china chinesen muss jetzt nicht sein also installieren desktop portal kd
so gut 6 multimedia fremend okay ja das ist okay einfach ein peck beste
warum muss ich irgendwelche karte dependencies installieren damit niri funktioniert
chat heil leute kurze frage schon das system mit 100 terabyte für unternehmen mit 150 user
gute idee eure erfahrung also zu tun dass selbst kann ich dir nichts sagen was ich in dem fall
tatsächlich viel wichtiger finde ist wenn also moment wo ich mal vorfangen willst du das bauen
für ein unternehmen oder arbeitest du in diesem unternehmen und bist beauftragt
sowas zu bauen sind zwei unterschiedliche paar schuhe
ansonsten als erstes will ich mir unabhängig von schulers oder was auch
immer mir gedanken machen wie ich ordentlich backups davon bekomme weil
100 terabyte sind schon ordentlich ja ob das alles sachen sind die gebackup
werden müssen weil früher oder später wird irgendwas kaputt gehen
Du brauchst auf jeden Fall ein Backup, sonst ist die Kacke am Dampfen.
Aber ansonsten sind 100T, würde ich sagen, ja durchaus im überschaubaren Rahmen.
Wenn man jetzt mittlerweile 24TB Platten hat, nimmst du 4 Stück oder so davon, dann hast du 690GB.
Du willst wahrscheinlich eher einen RAID 6 haben, vermute ich mal.
Kein RAID 5.
zwei Parity-Platten,
nimmst du sechs Platten.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das ein großes Problem ist.
Kommt halt drauf an,
was ihr machen wollt.
Also 150 User alleine heißt ja nichts.
Also es gibt ja die Möglichkeit,
die haben da irgendwelche Daten liegen,
wo 150 User zeitgleich irgendwelche
Images von streamen oder sowas.
Oder es ist halt ein File-Share,
wo ab und zu mal drauf zugegriffen wird.
Für ein File-Share, wo ab und zu mal drauf
zugegriffen wird,
mach. Da brauchst du wahrscheinlich
noch nicht jetzt mal ein wahnsinnig krasses
fettes Ding.
Aber ansonsten würde ich mir über das Anwendungsprofil
erstmal Gedanken machen.
Aber tunas kannst du da auf jeden Fall für benutzen.
Das ist wohl wahr, ja.
VM für Falsche,
andere VMs und so.
Du brauchst keine
VM für File-Shares mit
Trunas
Wenn du mehr Virtualisierung machen willst
Dann würde ich mir tatsächlich eher Proxmox angucken
Weil Virtualisierung
Das habe ich das letzte Mal ja ausprobiert
In einem der letzten Streams
Also Virtualisierungsmäßig ist
Proxmox meilenweit
Vor Trunas
Hast du eigentlich einen OLED-Monitor?
Ne, aber mein nächster Monitor wird wahrscheinlich
Einer
So, hier sind wir.
Niri, bam.
Äh, Chat?
Chat?
Ist das jetzt gecrashed?
Ich bin tot.
Crash, gell?
Das ist komplett...
Das ist komplett abgekackt.
Das ist so dead, dass ich nicht mal meine VM ausschalten kann.
Doch, jetzt.
Jetzt...
Okay, das war schon ziemlich dead.
Startet man Niri überhaupt so?
Wir gucken mal kurz.
Niri Arch.
Install.
Also die sagen ja auch, ich soll Portal GTK installieren.
Mal.
YouTube Niri Arch.
In 2026.
Okay.
How to install and customize Niri.
Okay, wie installiert man Niri? Zeig her.
Installation.
Hätte nicht gedacht, dass ich zu blöd bin,
Niri zu installieren, aber sieht so aus.
So, okay, Portal GTK
müssen wir installieren.
Jetzt hängt es wieder.
Chat, ich tendiere dazu,
CacheOS nochmal neu zu installieren.
Ähm...
Mit Niri.
Und dann schmeiß ich den ganzen Kempel runter, den ich nicht brauche.
Okay, also zeigt mir, wie installiere ich hier...
Was, was?
Niri Noctalia Sch...
Ja.
Ja, der fragt mich jetzt gar nicht nach.
Das ist natürlich Blödsinn.
Und ich hab keinen Snapshot gemacht.
Sedge, sedge, sedge.
Warum ist das so kaputt?
Das ist massive broken gerade.
Wollen wir vielleicht so machen und dann startet das irgendwie?
Okay, das ist schon
ziemlich kaputt, wie ich finde.
Gut, okay.
Scheiß drauf. Restart.
Wir
Hat das jetzt gecheckt?
Der checkt nicht, da ich Escape gedrückt habe.
Vmware, warum bist du so scheiße geworden?
So.
Okay.
Dann starten wir jetzt.
Dann installiere ich jetzt Niri und dann werfe ich einfach die komplette Config in einem Heimatverzeichnis weg.
das haben wir das letzte mal ja auch gemacht das hat ja funktioniert ffz oder 7 tv ffz ffz
als browser plugin und wenn du für deinen eigenen channel viele e mails brauchst dann 7 tv
Sag mal
Ist das irgendwie gerade kaputt
As fuck
Ah ne jetzt funktioniert es okay
Launcher
Aber das ganze Spiel nochmal
Oh, habe ich jetzt zu schnell geklickt, Leute?
American English.
Next.
Europe.
German.
Next.
Group.
Erased Disk.
Next.
Niri.
Max.
Next.
Install.
Yes.
ich hatte mir schon hier drauf installiert überhaupt kein problem hat das letzte mal
ohne jegliche probleme funktioniert wie gesagt ansonsten mache ich auf dem mini pc
aber ehrlich gesagt will ich das lieber nach vorn haben weil das von der handhabung
zum initial so vom scratch einrichten einfacher ist
Schauen wir mal.
Schauen wir mal, was das macht.
Reschke.
Ja.
Was war Niri nochmal written in?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Im Zweifelsfall, wenn es cool ist
und neu ist, dann Rust.
Gucken wir mal. GitHub, Niri.
Aber
Ich stelle mir das sehr Pains Champ vor.
Oh, das sieht nach Rust aus, wenn ich hier schon Cargo-Logs sehe.
Ja.
Blazingly fast, Leute.
2500 Zeilen Rust.
Blazingly fast.
Rustentiere.
Slack, leck, leck, leck, leck.
Gut, dann werde ich mich ein...
Ich werde auf jeden Fall einen Snapshot machen nach der Installation.
Dann werde ich alle Config-Dateien löschen, die es schon gibt,
für Niri und sonstige Geschichten.
Und auch Shells und so aninstallen.
Also mit, ich meine jetzt diese Wayland-Shells.
und dann richten wir das mal
from scratch ein.
Ah, den CacheOS-Kernel
brauche ich nicht. Mir war es eigentlich nur,
weil es standardmäßig die Cache-Repos drin hat.
Das muss ja auch so funktionieren.
Insidierst du bei einer
vor allem immer die OpenVM-Tools? Ja, ohne
OpenVM-Tools kannst du sie nicht benutzen.
Der Hype um Hyperland ist ein bisschen
out, habe ich den Eindruck.
aktuell hat hat miri
und wie heißt das andere
es gibt doch so drei sachen die es gerade angesagt sind miri es ist glaube ich mir die hyperland und noch irgendwas
glaube der hype schifft gerade ein bisschen zu miri
Wobei das ist ja jedes halbe jahr was neues gehabt ist
mango ja das war nicht install bootloader let's go restart und jetzt
prege das cash ist nicht gerade irgendwie kaputten stand hat und es
nicht booten oder sowas.
3, 2, 1.
Let's go.
Aha.
Easy, geht. Ohne Probleme.
Das ist ja der hässlichste
Login-Manager, den ich je gesehen habe,
Alter.
Da sind wir.
So.
Das will ich aber alles nicht haben.
Das will ich alles nicht haben.
Puzzle haben die da vor...
Hier, was ist das?
Okay, also.
Sudo, Pac-Man, minus S.
Ja, ja, Spine-San. Jawohl.
So, yes.
Dann ZSH.
Haben wir schon installiert.
Zisch.
Kann ich gleich mal
ins Heusch rüber kopieren. Zisch.
Äh, was?
Does this look like a diamond
rotated square?
Was? Das da.
Äh, yes.
Was passiert hier?
Yes.
quit do nothing besser
das ist ja auch noch das muss alles weg das muss alles leute es muss alles weg
rm rm minus erstmal snapshot machen erst mal ein snapshot machen das muss alles weg
rm-rf
zischer c
bärnchen, bam, weg
äh
config ordner
cache weg
config weg
local weg, alles weg
bam
so wie nackiges heimatverzeichnis
videos weg
templates weg
projects weg, public weg
Pictures weg
Music weg
Documents weg
Desktop weg
So
Das sieht doch schon besser aus
Bam
Jawoll
Das gefällt mir doch schon besser
War das ein Captcha im Terminal?
Nee, das ist irgendwie was, was der Prompt erkennt,
ob das Sonderzeichen anzeigen lassen kann
und Icons und sowas.
Okay, Niri ist am Start.
Ich muss Niri noch neu starten.
Weil ich hab hier die ganze Config gelöscht eben.
Wie startet man Niri neu?
Session-Menü?
Reboot.
Was, direkt rebooten?
So, let's go.
Clean Install.
Jetzt muss ich diesen hässlichen Login Manager hier noch wegschmeißen.
Oh ne, ich hab schon wieder gedacht, schon wieder broken.
das ist lx de oder wie dieser chat ich bin dumm ich habe das weg geklickt was ist terminal
es der interesse was war das terminal starten noch mal ich habe es weg gedrückt
Minus Shift T? Shift T, okay.
Change Shell?
Äh, wie war das nochmal?
Bin?
User Bin?
Ne, das war Minus L, oder?
Oder war es Minus I?
Oh Gott, das kann ich mir noch nicht merken.
Einfach nur so?
Ich bin zu dumm für Firefox.
Linux, wie ging das?
Minus S ist es?
Okay.
Krass.
Das macht man genau einmal pro Installation.
Wenn ich jetzt noch richtig schreiben könnte, wäre auch extrem die user bin zsh.
Okay, haben wir gemacht.
So wie exited maniri so anscheinend.
Also das Ding muss weg.
Das ist wirklich super hässlich.
Super T Open Terminal Run Application Launcher habe ich nicht installiert.
Okay.
Trading.
Genau, das will ich haben.
Okay, sehr gut.
Was ist das hier für ein komisches Terminal?
Was bin ich hier?
Okay.
Okay, das ist jetzt wirklich sehr minimalistisch.
Dann werden wir als erstes nochmal ein gescheites Terminal installieren.
Westterm Git.
Gibt es da vielleicht auch Westterm Nightly Bin?
Das gefällt mir ehrlich gesagt besser als Westerm Git,
weil Westerm Git wird wahrscheinlich jetzt erstmal eine halbe Stunde compilen oder so.
So, jetzt haben wir es.
Es ist aber wirklich sehr minimalistisch.
Warum, warum, Moment.
Warum sind hier wieder Desktop-Documents, Downloads und sowas da?
Das habe ich doch eben alles gelöscht.
wieso nicht das aus dem repo nehmen weil das von 2024 ist zu alt ich brauche
neueres
zeigt ja auch warum guck mal
auf
Guck mal.
Fällt dir was auf?
Das Western von 2024
ist verbuggt unter Wayland.
Mit dem Auszeiger.
Das kann ich ja überhaupt nicht abhaben.
Indiskutabel hier.
Komplett indiskutabel.
Ich brauche einen Mauszeiger, der sich der Sache hier anpasst.
Sonst geht das ja nicht.
Was für einen XDG-Portal hat das denn jetzt eigentlich installiert?
Was so?
XDG-Desktop-Portal.
Einfach WLR.
Okay.
Und GTK.
Aha.
So.
Und was war das jetzt? SDMM?
Wie heißt dieses Ding?
Ne.
SDDM.
Weg.
Meine Maus vor und zurück Taste geht nicht mehr.
Yes.
Nämlich, ich brauche gar keinen Login-Manager
Wisst ihr, das ist eine Sache, die verstehe ich nicht
Warum wollen Leute überhaupt einen Login-Manager haben?
Äh
Wenn ich crashke
Weil ich kann doch einfach auch so sagen
Miri, bam
Äh
Okay
Das ist doch viel besser
Monka piepsen
Ich würde gerne hier zwischen meinen Shells umschalten lassen.
Da.
Das ist der übelste Kackgebacke.
Moment, F1 und...
What the fuck?
Das...
Ach, ich kack noob, alter.
Das Logitech Ding
buggt ja rum mit F1.
Ich glaube, das buggt immer noch rum mit F1.
Ja, das ist mein Logitech
Treiber, der mit F1 rum
buggt. Das benutze ich
doch sonst immer zum Desktop umschalten.
Ähm.
Kann man das nicht disable irgendwie?
Disable.
Excellent.
Ach ne, Moment, jetzt habe ich es disabled.
Das Abled ist auch schlecht.
Dann macht es ja gar nichts mehr.
Äh,
Justifold.
Justifold, okay.
Okay, der hat gar keinen Bock mehr.
Wie kann ich denn jetzt
einstellen, dass der mir
beim Hochfahren
einfach ein Login-Fenster gibt.
Anstatt es jetzt
zu hängen.
So, aber das haben wir schon mal.
Jetzt ist der ganze Mist uninstalled.
Reboot.
Mal gucken.
Mal gucken, ob er jetzt hängt oder ob er überhaupt irgendwas macht.
Oh je, Leute.
Jetzt haben wir es zerstört.
Das kann doch nicht sein, Alter
Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Wenn man das aninstallt, dann geht's kaputt
Und auf andere
switchen geht auch nicht
musst du nicht noch so du system cdl set default multi user tage aus dem wirklich
ich würde gerne überhaupt mal was ausführen was ist das für ein schwachsinn das ist ja
mal voll für den Arsch. Okay,
Chatge, zack, Snapshot,
Restore.
Das ist das erste, was wir
fixen müssen. Das andere ist erstmal egal.
Plymorph.
Der ganze Gedöns würde ich normalerweise nie einrichten.
Ich uninstall das jetzt alles.
Bam.
Was?
Cache US, Boot Animation.
Cache US, Theme.
Weg. Bam.
Weg damit.
Okay, was meinst du?
System CTL?
Set Default. Das habe ich
legit noch nie ausgeführt.
Multi. Moment, Moment.
Kann ich jetzt nicht sagen Get Default?
Graphical Target.
Ach so.
Ja, das kann sein.
Das kann sein.
Reboot.
Ah, yes.
Excellent.
Kann ich das jetzt wieder installieren?
Und was passiert dann, wenn ich das jetzt wieder installiere?
Kriege ich dann diese coole
Cache-OS-Animation immerhin noch?
Das muss ich mal ausprobieren
Oder geht das nur wenn ich auf
Graphical umschalte
Was heißt System CTL
Get Default
Die Multi-User
Was habe ich denn eben uninstalled davor
Weiß man nicht mehr
Ich glaube das war alles
Reboot.
Oh, guck mal da.
Okay, ganz ehrlich, diesen Boot-Screen
kann ich mir komplett...
Kann ich mir komplett schenken.
Boah, ey.
Ich komme mit Fisch nicht klar.
So, jetzt haben wir das alles aninstallt.
Perfekt.
So, und jetzt noch einmal.
Was?
Cannot be found.
Ja, das soll mir recht sein.
Okay.
So, rm minus rf.
Also.
Exchange shell erst einmal minus es user bin
TSH so
Das da rm ist was rm sternchen bäm
Und hier auch
Sternchen
Exzellent leeres heimatverzeichnis so magisch dass so muss das sein so jetzt reboot
Okay, Funst, sehr gut.
Excellent. High IQ Chat.
Äh, create.
So, jetzt haben wir
ein komplett nagisches System.
So wie das sein muss.
So, wir können Niri starten, indem wir Niri eingeben.
Und hab jetzt einen nackigen Neri-Desktop.
Oder Desktop kann man es ja nicht wirklich nennen.
Sehr schön.
Da werden wir doch jetzt noch mal kurz
einen Snapshot machen.
Einen Snapshot löschen.
Und dann können wir anfangen.
Also.
Ctrl-T.
Öffnet
Allakriti. Allakriti wollen wir ja nicht haben.
Das ist, guck mal,
das ist ein bisschen magnetisch, wenn man hier dran zieht.
Dann schalte ich mal meine
VM hier ein, die andere, weil davon müssen wir uns jetzt ein paar
ähm,
Configs ziehen.
Starten wir mal
einen SSH-Server auf dem Ding.
Gucken wir mal, Firefox, ne Firefox brauchen wir gerade, egal, aus damit, kein Firefox,
weg so system ctl restart ssh wir haben hier ip 146 146 ssh max at 122.146 yes
Passwort. Sehr gut.
Jetzt sind wir auf der anderen
Kiste.
Gut. Dann wollen wir doch
mal.
Erstmal kopieren wir uns hier von
Okay, meine
Vor- und Zurück-Taste geht schon mal nicht. Das ist schon mal
ganz abartig.
SCP.
Der frisst auch SCP.
So, jetzt kopieren wir uns jetzt erstmal.
Z.
Moment, wir machen erstmal SSH Keygen.
Okay, jetzt sagen wir SSH Copy ID Max Ad.
Der frisst Tastendrücke, ne?
Ich hoffe, das macht er nicht weiterhin, weil ansonsten ist es ja unusable.
guck mal der aktualisiert auch manchmal nicht seht ihr das der back manchmal okay
so jetzt sagen wir scp max 2.146 doppelpunkt sollte nicht eigentlich auto kompleten jetzt
ZSHRC
Okay, schon viel besser.
Also Starship müssen wir installieren.
Yes.
Okay.
Dann installieren wir SCP.
Kopieren wir uns rüber.
Der hat es nicht gespeichert.
SCP.
Max at 1.1.1.1.1.
Config?
Warum habe ich kein Auto complete?
Doch, habe ich.
Habe ich doch.
Config?
Starship?
Hummel?
Äh.
Ach so.
Ich bin ja auch blöd.
mv starship tommel nach config
das fühlt sich
laggy an, irgendwas stimmt hier nicht
der frisst
Astendrücke und so
ok, so
meine shell sieht schon mal zumindest halbwegs normal aus
wieder, damit bin ich
soweit zufrieden
nur dass ich nicht
aller kriti will, sondern west term
installieren wir mal das western aus dem aus dem repo und dann kompilieren wir uns das extra
kommt man der aktualisiert manchmal einfach nicht habt ihr das gesehen so lange wie das
da gerade gebraucht hat das packt western
so scp config western kann ich nicht einfach sagen
ähm, minus R
nach Config.
Geht das nicht auch so?
Was ich da jetzt, Punkt Config.
Was?
Hack gibt es nicht. Okay.
Äh, warum nicht?
Was hat der für, Hack fehlt als Font.
Na gut, okay.
Hier ist es doch.
Hier ist doch mal ein West Term.
Ja.
Das sieht doch schon mal nach einem halbwegs gescheiten Terminal wieder aus.
Hack Font.
Guck mal, der aktualisiert manchmal den Bildschirm nicht.
Da ist irgendwas broken noch.
Was da wollen wir haben?
Irgendwas, irgendwas.
stimmt da nicht.
Hack gibt es nicht. Warum gibt es das nicht? Ich habe doch
tt tt fhack installiert die tfx otf hack nerd und das installieren
kommen wir mal jetzt kommt man aktualisiert manchmal das ist ganz wird wird champ
okay das gefällt mir doch schon mal deutlich besser so jetzt ist die frage wie stelle ich
Niri um. Config.
Niri.
Config hier.
So.
Wer macht denn standardmäßig
Wim-Modus an?
So, SCP.
Kopieren wir uns mal
die Wim-RC.
Wim-RC hier hin.
So, Config. Niri.
Es fühlt sich etwas
laggy an hier, muss man echt sagen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das an Alakriti liegt oder ob das an Niri liegt.
So, wie kann ich jetzt hier...
Also hier wird irgendwo Alakriti gestartet.
Das wollen wir nicht.
Wir wollen nicht Alakriti starten, sondern Western.
Exzellent.
Sehr schön, das gefällt mir schon mal gut.
Ich habe auch den Eindruck, das lag ein bisschen weniger.
ihr fonds und anzeige und so pass auf das einzige was mir halt auf den sack geht ist ihr seht das
ja dass der mauszeiger nicht aktualisiert hier erst wenn ich reinklicke wird es zu einem terminal
was schon doof das kann man das dann müssen wir nämlich eine neue western version installieren
Aber ich meine, ich fand es ja an sich schon mal ganz gut.
Was ich jetzt ganz cool finden würde, ehrlich gesagt,
wenn ich jetzt
Western Git installiere,
onks,
dann braucht es wieder drei Stunden,
weil ich das erstmal komplett from scratch kompilieren muss.
Ich würde sagen, wir fokussieren uns erstmal
hier auf Niri.
Ich hoffe, Western bringt einfach bald ein neues Release raus.
Gut.
Dann kopieren wir uns, wenn wir jetzt gerade schon dabei sind, SCP.
Kopieren wir uns noch die History, meine Shell History.
Excellent.
So, und dann Edit hier VMChamp, CubeCTL raus, CubeCTL raus, VMChamp raus und Deno raus.
Deno benutze ich doch eh nicht mehr.
So, okay.
Das gefällt mir schon etwas besser, damit kommt mir jetzt halbwegs klar.
Dann wollen wir uns mal um Niri kümmern.
Config Niri.
Also als erstes muss ich diese komischen...
Ne, Moment mal.
Vorher, der Mauszeiger muss umgestellt werden.
Wie ändert man den Mauszeiger in Niri?
Soll ich nach Cursor vielleicht suchen?
kurs geht schon mal nicht
ja jetzt haben wir haben noch nicht mal ein application launcher am start da
lassen sie mal kurz checken miri change maus cursor
change cursor hier input cursor wie bata modern classic ist das so
zumindest müssen wir vorher noch new blog firefox new blog muss man installieren
Jetzt.
Aha.
ok konzert niri und input hier irgendwie macht man das so keyboard touchpad maus da okay was
Was sagt der Chat dazu?
Cursor!
Aha!
Was ist X-Wayland Satellite?
Clipboard disabled?
Cursor?
Change the theme and size of the cursor as well as the X-Cursor.
Theme and X-Cursor.
Moment.
Ich muss den Chat erstmal hier in die VM kriegen,
weil Copy-Pasten kann ich da mit Sicherheit
von Windows aus jetzt nix.
Ne, kann ich auch nicht.
Das heißt, wir machen jetzt
mal hier
Chatterino installieren.
Wie, gab's das nicht?
Chat, hatte ich das das letzte Mal nicht?
Gab's das nicht irgendwie in den Standard?
Na gut.
Dann kompilieren wir uns Chatrino jetzt selbst.
Ich weiß, wir könnten auch das Bin installieren, aber wurscht.
Ich hab doch gar kein Java installiert.
Ist das nicht Java-based?
Okay, sie drei Stunden später.
Nicht, dass es zu einfach wird.
Wenn wir gerade schon dabei sind, kommen wir H-Top.
H-Top gibt es auch nicht.
Okay, dann müssen wir das gleiche mal installieren.
Und macht es was für sein Geld?
Remove, no.
Das war es schon?
Ne, das sind jetzt die Dependencies.
Hat Jeterino nicht
Java-based?
Oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander?
Ne, offensichtlich nicht
Java-based. C++-based.
Weil, cute.
Wird ordentlich
ausgelastet hier. 5 CPU-Kerne.
100% ausgelastet.
So, und wenn das mit dem Cursor funktioniert,
dann müssen irgendwie dieser fette Rahmen
und die Gaps ein bisschen kleiner.
Guck dir mal.
Ich mach das hier mal kurz weg.
Guck mal, die Gaps, die sind riesengroß.
Alter, das hältst du ja nicht aus.
Und auch dieser fette Rand da.
Vielleicht können wir das sogar schon machen, während Chatterino installiert.
War das denn nicht...
Lirikonf.
Gibt es sowas wie Gaps?
Ah, Gaps 16.
Excellent.
Gaps 2.
Ich glaube, 4.
Okay.
Und jetzt...
Irgendwas Outline vielleicht?
Outline?
Nee.
Aber wie könnte das heißen, dieses Ding, was hier außen drumherum ist?
Border? Border?
Fokusring heißt es. Fokusring.
Okay.
Zwei.
Ja, schon viel besser.
Viel besser.
Wie sieht es mit 1 aus?
Ja.
Perfekt.
So ist gut.
So, Gap.
Auch mal Gaps.
Bisschen vielleicht.
Ja, so ist gut.
Optimal.
So lassen wir das.
So ist gut.
Perfekt.
Anderer Fokusring Farbe.
Ich find das eigentlich so ganz okay. So fast das Blau was ich...
Das muss ich mir dann auch überlegen was ich da... Aber das ist erstmal okay.
Schadrino kompiliert noch. So, dann müssen wir Maus Cursor installieren.
die barter cursor die barter cursor team das brauchen wir muss auch selbst
kompiliert werden das körper kompilieren chatarino baut auch noch yes
Das sieht schon ganz brauchbar aus jetzt schon auf den ersten Blick finde ich so.
Vom Auer muss man immer selbst kompilieren.
Ne, da sind Build Scripts dabei.
Das heißt nicht, dass du unbedingt automatisch selbst kompilieren musst.
Es gibt meistens auch ein Minus-Bin-Repo.
Da lädt er dann das fertig vorkompilierte Binary schon runter.
Yes.
Okay, sehr schön.
Chatterino sollte hoffentlich auch bald soweit sein.
und dann gehen wir mal hier die config durch was man hier alles so machen kann
chatarino am start immer auf dem zweiten also ich habe ich habe kein application
launcher ich habe keine application launcher das natürlich ein bisschen
unpraktisch wie moment wie wie wie
eine twitch channel wo blotts da sind wir leute
sondern hier gibt es die übersicht
Wie man das mit dem Cursor macht.
Cursor.
X-Cursor-Theme.
Breeze-Cursor.
Also so muss man das machen.
Das heißt
Das war jetzt wo ganz
Ganz außerhalb
Oder wie war das jetzt
Ne so
So weit bin ich noch nicht
Dass ich die Vibe code
Ähm
Top Level
Okay also heißt im Endeffekt
nur dass ich das jetzt richtig verstehe
ich geh jetzt hier rein
und sag das hier
und dann passiert nix
doch, hä, what the fuck
deswegen brauch ich ein neues Westterm
Breeze Cursors, das wollen wir ja nicht, wir wollen
Bibata
Niri
Bibata Cursor
Wie Bata Modern Amber will ich haben, glaube ich.
Ich glaube Amber. Modern Amber heißt das.
Okay, Ice müsste auch funktionieren.
Ah.
Aber guck mal, Westterm checkt es nicht.
So, Hide when typing wollen wir nicht.
Hide inactive wollen wir auch nicht.
Amber.
Michael, fünf Spilianen, moin.
Okay, perfekt.
Größe 28.
Exzellent, Leute.
Ist das nicht.
So, okay.
Ihr seht, ich brauche auf jeden Fall ein neues West Herm.
Weil mein West Herm checkt es null.
mit der, mit
das Back mit Wayland rum.
Wir können nochmal was checken.
Config, Western, Western Lua,
Wayland,
irgendwie Render oder so.
Frontend.
Oh, da muss ich mich dran gewöhnen
Dieses, das, das mit dem, mit dem
Das ist mir zu viel, ey
Kann ich das nicht auf Desktop 2
Verschieben oder so?
Hm
Wir haben jetzt ja nur drei Fenster
Western Wayland
Enable Wayland
Enable Wayland gleich true
Jetzt muss ich das höchstwahrscheinlich stoppen
Und jetzt
Ah, guck mal
Jetzt ist das Wayland enabled
Exzellent!
Guckt hier, jetzt passt es auch. Sehr schön! So kann man das Terminal auch verwenden.
Die Farbe passt nicht? Wieso nicht?
Das ist doch exakt die gleiche Farbe, die ich bei der anderen VM auch habe, oder?
Vielleicht nicht
Welche Farbe meinst du denn?
Die hier außen rum, oder was?
Ach, die vom Cursor.
Die beißt sich mit deinem Theme.
Ja, das ist Absicht, dass ich die Maus nicht, dass ich den Mauszeiger erkenne.
doch ich brauchte es so aber updates machen weil nicht blieb genug gut damit komme ich jetzt schon
mal klar jetzt brauchen wir irgend ein application launcher was also normalerweise ich bin ja ich bin
ja profi fan aber vielleicht sollte ich mal was anderes ausprobieren machen noch
dieses ding rein dass sein grund das fonds leider ich das ist ein kde only ding
Puzzle.
Okay.
Config.
Niri.
Wo sieht man denn hier, was der startet?
Müssen wir Westterm suchen?
Was?
Was passiert hier?
Warum hat Westterm eine Windows-Rule?
Was macht das jetzt?
Puzzle.
Okay.
Ich gucke mir das mal an, ob mir das gefällt oder nicht.
also das team gefällt mir schon mal an 0
also ich benutze das halt guck mal leute ich benutze das halt für mehrere sachen
also habe ich zumindest früher mal ich habe das zum launchen von apps benutzt
verwendet nie windows benutzt ja auch nie als emoji picker als clipboard
manager und um pass also im prinzip im archipel clipboard manager und apps so
wenn ich das wenn ich das mit fussel auch alles machen kann dann ist okay
aber das ich finde das schon mal ganz okay aus
input maus scroll faktor höher was ich gerne hätte ich muss ein bisschen schneller repeat
Müssten ein bisschen schneller sein.
So.
I3-Config gibt es nicht mehr.
Es gibt Config Niri.
Und dann war das Config.
.kdl oder sowas.
Okay.
So.
Mod plus T. Das wollen wir schon mal.
Mod plus Enter wollen wir für
terminal haben geht nicht return return ist es profi ist das screen locken mache
jenet und schulde ist sie nicht dafür ja
mod mod shift slash macht bei mir nichts
mod shift slash
aber ganz ehrlich ich brauche auch kein shortcut overlay das werde ich mir alles
so einrichten dass ich es merken kann super alt plus es erlauben lockt es
super alt super alt es
das ist ein beispiel dafür wie man shell kommandos spawnen kann okay das lasse ich mal drin
volume keys mapping mache ich eh nicht
mod o ist overview aha okay ich verkehrt gibt es was die repeat ich meine repeat für die taste
also für für keyboard wie man also wisst ihr wie ich meine ich will dass hier das schneller passiert
wenn ich Taste gedrückt halte.
Input.
Firefox.
Okay, wir müssen das mal so machen, dass ich da dran
gewöhnt bin. Wie ich dran gewöhnt bin.
Also, erster Desktop kommt
Firefox Fullscreen. Zweiter
Desktop kommt Western
Fullscreen. So, da komme ich
doch schon besser mit klar.
repeat delay
kann man den firefox dark theme
einschalten
ok, excellent
aber gut, aha
oh, was jetzt
jetzt hat es irgendwie rumgebackt
Delay.
Repeat Delay.
Repeat Rate.
Repeat Delay wollen wir.
Repeat Delay.
Ich glaube 250 oder so habe ich da.
Ich bin mir da gar nicht sicher ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, kommt ungefähr hin.
Ich muss mal kurz in der anderen Geschichte hier.
X.
XZ.
300.
300 und
Repeat Rate 40.
40.
So, heißt im Endeffekt, ich gehe jetzt hier hin, drück.
Ja, das fühlt sich ziemlich gut wie das
alte an. Nublock Enable
Default mäßig finde ich gut.
Nier will Fetch.
Ja, aber Layout ist jetzt German Layout. Das ist okay.
Touchpad habe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht. Das werde ich einfach mal rausschmeißen.
Maus kann da bleiben.
Der Mauszeiger ruckelt ein bisschen, ne?
Der ruckelt. Guckt mal, im Vergleich zu dem hier, hier ist der Butt. Seht ihr das?
Moment, Chat.
Seht ihr überhaupt was?
Mein Vorschaubildschirm war gerade schwarz.
Guck mal hier.
Hier ist der Mauszeiger super weich.
Und hier ruckelt der Mauszeiger.
Seht ihr das?
Das kann ich so nicht benutzen.
Das ist unusable.
Open VM.
Das liegt bestimmt an Wayland.
100 Pro.
1000 Pro liegt es an Wayland.
power of bern probieren wir mal was aus und zwar mama accelerate 3d graphics aus
sollte eigentlich eher das gegenteil bewirken nämlich dass es langsamer ist
oder schlechter performt aber mal gucken bei vor allem bei workstation heißt ja
mittlerweile nie. Max? Miri? Ohne 3D Acceleration crasht es komplett.
Excellent, excellent.
Ich kann nicht mehr.
Das ist unusable mit ruckelndem Mauszeiger.
Vergiss es einfach mit ruckelndem Mauszeiger.
Ich werde das jetzt aber ordentlich einrichten in der VM.
Weil da können wir viel besser rumprobieren und basteln.
Und mir dann einfach die Config auf meinem Mini-PC kopieren.
Ne, ne, ne. Sorry, nicht Static. Es ist Miri.
Ja, oh, das ist laggy. Das riecht laggy.
Das ist richtig laggy, der Mauszeiger.
Ne ne ne ne ne, das ist wirklich unusable.
Ich hab so viele nasses.
Ja und da kommt aber nicht wenig drauf.
Aber Neri selbst ist ja so eigentlich ganz gut eingerichtet.
Was ich mich jetzt noch frage ist, wie kann ich denn jetzt Anwendungen verschieben zum Beispiel.
Also mal angenommen, ich würde jetzt gerne, ich mache jetzt hier noch ein Terminal auf und das würde ich jetzt gerne verschieben auf den ersten Desktop.
Oder auf den ersten Workspace oder auf die erste Zeile oder wie auch immer man es nennen mag.
Da müssen wir mal hier kurz gucken.
äh, Output.
Moment, kann man da vielleicht was dran drehen?
Ähm.
Äh.
Du hast mit von meinem Workstation Niri keine Probleme?
Du hast bestimmt auch ein leichtes Mauszeiger-Ruckeln.
Mit X habe ich da 0.
Hast du 3D-Acceleration an oder aus?
Was passiert, wenn ich das jetzt ankommente?
Nichts.
ähm ähm wie krieg ich denn
den Namen von meinem
Output überhaupt raus
Neri Message Outputs
Virtual Virtual One
Ja, der unterstützt halt nur 60, ne
Okay, immerhin
Würde der das prinzipiell anscheinend checken
At 120
Checkt er halt nicht
At 60, machen wir jetzt
Oder auch nicht.
Warum ist das jetzt alles so fett?
Position?
Was?
Null.
Das soll mein erster Monitor sein.
Äh.
Warum ist das jetzt so, so, so?
Ach, Scale 2.
Ich muss Scale 1 machen, ne?
Ah, ja, okay.
Ey, es ist laggy.
Warte mal, warte mal, warte mal.
1 FPS, keck, wait.
Bringt nichts, macht keinen...
Macht keinen Unterschied.
Kein Unterschied.
Der Mauszeiger ruckelt tatsächlich jetzt ein bisschen weniger.
Aber das kann man ja erstmal so lassen.
Das ganze Comments-Zeug, das irritiert mich.
Das ist doch guter Code, dokumentiert sich selbst.
Oh, das ist ja alles weg.
animation speed müsste auch noch hoch ja das stimmt an die animations
auf fast noch lieber ja viel besser aber gar keine animations mehr
wl andere ja doch dass das
das ist ja der kleine das ist halt dieses dieses von vm ja das kann
wundern dass das nicht funktioniert
ok preferred current ist das doch das gleiche
ok gut screenshot path
also das hier machen wir alles
keyboard
das brauchen wir nicht das kann alles raus maus an dem prinzip auch raus
track point kann auch aus alles default oder was kann die maus noch was kann man
bei der maus einstellen celebration profile ich stelle jetzt einfach mal irgendwas ein
endet am geruckelt von der maus nichts ich straße jack point fliegt raus
ist okay layout das kann man drin lassen gaps center focus kann meinetwegen
reset color mit das ist wenn ich mehrere sachen starte wie groß das ist
also quasi immer einen drittel so jetzt hingeht drittel drittel tritt
überhaupt nicht immer ein drittel dann check ich dann check ich das nicht
egal kommen es auch daten overrated gebetet default column with ach so you can change
ach hier die hälfte ist das ja aber jetzt haben wir hier 0,0 3 und jetzt auch nicht
Dann check ich es nicht.
Ach so.
Ah.
Jetzt.
Okay, verstehe.
Die Sachen gibt es zur Auswahl.
Ah, ja.
Okay.
Hyperland funzt nicht in der VM.
Weiter.
Das hätte ich doch schon längst ausprobiert.
Ich kann es ja auf einem Mini-PC ausprobieren.
Border off.
Moment, das ist jetzt quasi Windows Border um alles rum.
Oh, fuck, Alter.
Was ist, wenn ich das ganz lösche?
Ist es dann off?
Okay, default ist off.
You can enable drop shadows.
Das will ich mal gucken, wie das aussieht.
Das erkenne ich wahrscheinlich nur.
Okay, ein bisschen, ein bisschen
erkennt man es. Aber ganz im Ernst.
Overrated, outdated, she baited.
Geh weg.
Strutz.
Okay, da weiß ich nicht, was es ist.
Ich lösche es auch einfach mal.
spawn at startup way bar schön habe ich nicht installiert kann man da lassen hotkey overlay
dass er das standardmäßig einblendet können wir uns auch schenken screenshot paar warum auch immer
animation settings animation sind alle auf das ist gut window rules ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher
Warum es dieses Western Rule braucht?
Äh, Chat?
Mein Terminal startet nicht mehr. War das vielleicht...
Braucht man das deswegen?
Oh ja, das fixt den Bug, dass das Terminal sich nicht öffnet. Gut, das lassen wir wahrscheinlich besser da.
ok das kann man auch da lassen schmeißen wir raus
das
round corners for all windows hier key bindings
hier sind die key bindings das muss uns gleich mal in ruhe angucken es gibt das mal wie viele
WTF wie viele key ach so das ist die letzte sektion die es da gibt wie viele key bindings okay open my terminal
Muss ich da eigentlich was hinschreiben spawn western perfekt
Mod D startet fussel
Das ist ein beispiel hier
Mod O ist overview
finde ich jetzt
eigentlich ganz cool.
Können wir mal lassen.
Mod Q ist
Close Window.
Ansonsten muss ich mich immer
an neue Dinger gewöhnen.
Das kannst du vergessen.
Shift plus Q.
Wenn ich das jetzt öffne, drück Shift plus Q, wird geschlossen.
Mod Left.
Was?
Achso, das ist einfach nur hier
durchschalten. Ja gut, das macht Sinn.
Das ist für die
Wim-Enjoyer. Kommt weg.
Ich bin zwar auch Wim-Enjoyer,
aber kein JKL-Enjoyer.
Mach mal
Hotkey-Overlay-Skip-At-Startup
wieder an, sonst öffnet
sich das immer beim Start.
Mal gucken,
ob es mich nervt. Wenn es mich nervt, dann
ja, wahrscheinlich nervt es mich.
Move Column Left
Also
Mod Control Left
Macht was?
Ah
Okay, ich kenn mich
Ich kenn mich, Leute
Ich werd das so gut wie nicht verwenden
Wahrscheinlich bin ich faul
Und track das lieber so rüber
Wow, wow, wow, wow
Oh, oh, oh
Was hab ich jetzt
Fuck
Jetzt hab ich's kaputt gemacht
Aber das ist nicht verkehrt.
Aber da machen wir nicht Control,
da machen wir Shift raus.
Shift.
Ups.
Zum Teufel.
zu viel magic
etwas habe ich falsch gemacht
irgendwas habe ich irgendwas habe ich gebraucht
Kann das sein, dass ich das doppelt belegt habe jetzt und es deswegen nicht mehr mag?
Anscheinend.
Okay, das kann sein, dass es schon belegt ist.
Mod Home?
Ah, das ist Anfang, Ende.
Okay, das ist nicht verkehrt.
Also wenn ich jetzt hier ganz viele Fenster auf habe, dann springt das ans Ende und das am Anfang.
Das finde ich ganz gut.
Das lassen wir mal.
Move Column to First.
Move Column to Last.
Das brauche ich nicht.
Mod Shift A.
Hier, Focus Monitor.
Monitor.
Monitor. Ich habe nur ein Monitor hier.
Das brauchen wir nicht.
Mod, Page Up,
Page Down. Das gleiche ist
das gleiche wie so im Endeffekt.
Brauche ich nicht.
Werde ich so durchschalten.
Move Column To
Works. Also die komplette
alle eins runter da bin ich mir noch nicht so ganz sicher
also wenn ich jetzt sag mod shift left verschiebt er das gut was doch
eigentlich also im prinzip im prinzip genauso wie ich das haben will
Weil ich ja nicht so ganz checke, wie ich das dann beispielsweise splitten kann.
Dass ich so machen kann.
Weil jetzt macht links und rechts ja nichts.
Okay, noch nicht ganz gecheckt, ehrlich gesagt.
mod shift page down mod shift page down
macht nix
You can bind mouse wheel scroll ticks using mod plus wheel scroll up.
Ach guck mal da kann man auch so durch scrollen. Das brauche ich nicht.
focus workspace 1234 move column workspace
ich will ehrlich gesagt gibt es nicht application workspace also wenn ich jetzt
Okay, wenn ich jetzt Mod...
Mod Control 2 drücke...
Dann hat das zum Workspace gemovt.
Ja, tatsächlich.
Aber ich will ja...
Jetzt hat er alles auf die 1 gemovt.
Wie kann ich denn eine einzelne Anwendung moven?
Column ist immer nur ein Fenster?
Oder doch ist es das
Control
Mod 2
Okay du hast recht
Ja gut dann wieder das gleiche
Hier
Dann wieder das gleiche
Zack
Zack, Shift
Jetzt kann ich sagen, hier das da
Soll auf 1
Und schon sind wir auf 1, das soll wieder runter auf 2
Ja, okay, das kann man so lassen
Können wir gucken
Ob Fast Horizontal Scrolling Animations nervig sind
Erstmal Chatterino starten
Da ich wieder den Chat hier am Start habe.
Also das kommt erstmal alles fort.
Was macht das?
Consume or Expel Windows Bracket.
Komme ich eh nicht dran.
Werde ich nie im Leben benutzen.
Das finde ich ganz praktisch.
Das werde ich mal lassen.
Resize.
Ja, die Höhe.
Ah
Okay, das finde ich tatsächlich gar nicht verkehrt
Äh
By the way
Äh, Chat, wie mache ich das jetzt
Wie mache ich das jetzt wieder Fullscreen
So, oder wie
Oder was
Ne, Mod plus F macht's das nicht
Mod plus F macht nur so.
Guck.
Nur das quasi das horizontale.
Also ich muss das selbst schieben.
Das ist ja komisch.
Nee, nee, nee.
Hä?
Kann es nicht?
Ach, Mod shift F ist Fullscreen.
Mod F ist Maximize Color.
Das kommt weg.
Das hier.
So.
Ja.
Das brauche ich.
Wenn ich mich kenne, werde ich das eh nicht verwenden.
So.
Center.
Full Universal.
Was?
Mod Control C.
mod
ctrl c
center
benutze ich auch nicht
achso das ist komplett
fullscreen achso
ok das ist dann doch nicht so geil
das ist dann doch nicht so geil
dann machen wir mal lieber
Wartet mal.
Ne, das wollen wir in der Tat nicht haben.
Wir wollen dann tatsächlich
lieber
Wir wollen dann lieber das hier haben.
Also Mod Control
F
macht das.
Das gleiche irgendwie.
Wie mach ich denn jetzt?
Fullscreen.
Also volle Höhe, volle Breite.
Reset Window Height.
Achso.
Das da meinste?
Control mit...
Ah!
Kann ich...
Okay, okay.
Jetzt kommt die Preisfrage.
Kann ich Mod Shift nicht sagen?
Maximize Column und Reset Window Height in einem.
Ja, entscheidend nicht, oder?
Neri Multiple Commands Bind.
Okay, das geht nicht.
Okay, das finde ich schon mal doof, dass das nicht funktioniert.
Ah.
Das heißt, ah, okay, okay, okay.
Das heißt, ich kann...
Hallo? Copy, paste, please.
Das heißt, ich kann quasi sowas machen.
Miri Message Action.
Und dann sagen...
Ähm...
Dann sowas hier, hä?
Ah ja, okay, okay
Okay
So ganz, so ganz klar
Komme ich damit noch nicht
Und dann nochmal
Nochmal das schicken und dann sagen
Reset Window halt
Window
Halt
Okay, sehr gut, excellent
Das will ich haben
So, und wie geht das jetzt?
Mod.
Mod plus F.
Mach einfach maximize column.
Okay.
Was sagst du?
Nö, macht's nicht.
Ähm, so und jetzt
Spawn SH.
Warum, warum
maximalist sich das Teil hier so komisch?
Von KS, oder?
Jetzt kommt
das hier rein.
also das copy-paste sagt ja mal richtig
das copy-paste nicht mehr das macht einfach nichts
irgendwelchen gründen geht steuerung fordern nicht
jetzt muss ich wahrscheinlich noch
Aha, Leute.
Es funzt.
Massive.
Skriptor-Stells.
Das kann aber noch nicht
im Sinne des Erfinders sein, oder?
Mod?
Was? Mod? Minus?
Ah.
Plus?
Mod Plus geht nicht.
Das werde ich auch nicht benutzen.
Das werde ich nicht benutzen.
Okay, ich kenne mich da.
Move the focus windows between the floating and the tiling layer.
Okay, das brauche ich.
Im Zweifelsfall.
Switch focus between floating and tiling.
Toggle windows.
Also kann ich sagen.
Mod Shift V
Was?
Jetzt floated es?
Jetzt floated es.
Jetzt hat es wieder aufzufloaten.
So, das muss sein. Mod plus Shift plus Space.
Damit ich damit klarkomme.
Ja, perfekt.
Was macht Maximize Windows to Edges?
Soll ich das mal ausprobieren?
Maximize Windows to Edges.
Wenn der Chat das sagt, dann probieren wir das aus.
Ah, das macht das gleiche.
Nee, nee, nee, das ist wie Fullscreen.
Das ist wie Fullscreen.
Das wollen wir auch nicht.
Nee, das muss man anscheinend so merkwürdig hier machen.
Das werde ich nicht benutzen.
Print macht das Screenshot.
Ah.
Space to save the Screenshot.
Okay, das finde ich gut, dass da sowas mit dabei ist.
Das gefällt mir schon mal.
Altprint.
Macht das Window.
Okay, das ist okay.
Moment, das muss ich jetzt mal lesen.
Kurz was.
Applications such as remote desktop clients
and KVM switches may request
that nearly stops processing
the keyboard shortcuts defined here.
vorbei escape ach so okay das ist dass man wieder rauskommen mod escape drückt
okay das lassen wir mal ein problem
so quitt action will show confirmation to avoid x ach so ja das ist okay shift
Mod E. Das ist wie bei E3.
Das kann ich mir... Power of Monitors
weg. So, wir haben eine
Nierikon-Floide.
Mit Keybindings, wo ich
halbwegs mit klarkomme.
Zumindest wenn ich so benutze
wie E3 erstmal, bis ich mich dran gewöhnt
habe.
Nächste wichtige
Sache. Ascii
Quario muss installiert werden.
Das ist immer ganz essentiell.
und C-Matrix.
Gut, Ackerman-Modus aktiviert.
Erstmal Tee trinken.
Stimmt, mein
Aff-Kloß-Skript habe ich jetzt hier gar nicht.
Das habe ich auf Mini-PC.
Komme ich aber erst mal mit klar so.
Gut.
Dass der Mauszeiger laggt, geht mir immer noch auf den Keks.
Kann ich hier eigentlich gescheit Copy-Paste, wenn ich das hier nehme?
Ja.
Okay, sehr gut
Gefällt mir, damit kommt man doch schon mal halbwegs klar, oder?
Jetplanes Toolbox muss installiert werden
Toolbox
Basta, jawoll, jawoll
Yes
Yes.
Cool Box.
Guck mal, der checkt sogar, dass das Floating sein soll.
Nicht schlecht, oder?
Acreed to the...
Jaja, Start.
Was ich als Bar benutzen werde?
Ne.
das machen wir aber nächsten stream dann da gibt es ja sich shells die wir ausprobieren können
was rover brauchen wir intelligent brauchen wir ein goal an brauchen wir peitscher brauner ab und
zu mal webstore bräuchte ein braun war leider brauchen war und geht für das war's erstmal
halbe Chatplane-Universum installieren.
Also eine Bar brauche ich auf jeden Fall dann noch.
Und auch ganz...
Leute, Leute, Leute. Ich habe ja fast...
Ich habe ja eine ganz wichtige Sache vergessen.
White Pepo Happy
GitHub.
warum gibt es hier noch mehr white people happy
ach nee der typ heißt so ja mk dir repos cd repos geht's clown so wie setzt
man denn jetzt miri einen background miri set background image das not come in
wallpaper utility use sway bg
sway bg
Okay, Sway, Sway, BG und dann gibt man einfach das Bild an oder was?
Gehen wir mal hier rein.
Sway, BG und irgendwie Soldering.
A minus I.
Da haben wir ihn.
Das wäre doch mal was, oder?
Dann können wir spielen
Twitch Chat Plays IDE
oder irgendwie sowas.
Kann das nicht im Background das Ganze machen?
Sway, BG, Don't Block.
Ja, das ist blöd.
Ah, das ist nichts, was wir jetzt lösen müssen.
Hauptsache, wir haben ein bisschen Background.
Übrigens, ich sehe gerade, das Terminal hat kaum Trans...
Das hat keine Transparenz.
Warum nicht?
Ich habe doch hier Opacity gesetzt.
Opacity 0.
Chat, das hat keine Opacity.
Warum nicht?
Neri, Window, Opacity.
Opacity hier.
Und der Westterm.
Opacity.
Außer, dass es immer blauer wird.
Sehe ich da jetzt nichts?
Ups.
Ja, dann halt keine Opacity.
Aber irgendwie ist das...
Irgendwas stimmt damit nicht.
Die geht ja nicht.
Hier.
Window Background Opacity.
Western Opacity Wayland.
Not working.
Capacity.
Frontend OpenGL.
OpenGL.
Juckt es nicht
Jetzt macht es gar nichts mehr
Jetzt vielleicht
Jetzt vielleicht diese Niri Geschichte hier
Okay, ich hab ne Idee, Leute.
Ich hab ne Idee.
Enable Wayland Falls.
bringt aber auch nichts oder
ganz vergessen das juckt das juckt es nicht
das ist dem egal okay vielleicht sollten wir uns doch ein eigen neues western
kompilen was ein bisschen moderner ist
ach guck mal da habt ihr es gerade gesehen
Wenn das...
Aber...
Wenn das Fenster aktiv ist...
Kann das sein, dass es für inaktiv...
Dass es nur inaktive gibt?
Dass aktive Fenster nicht das Background durchscheinen haben?
Das könnte ja sein.
Ja, das ist so.
Guck mal hier, 99.
Ja, guck.
Das ist so.
Jetzt müssen wir dem noch beibringen.
Ähm.
Opacity.
Ich will ja das Gegenteil haben.
Okay, so hundertprozentig
ist es noch nett.
Aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher,
dass das alles fixbar ist.
Hier, Mauswheel brauchen wir nicht.
Sowas hier?
Ne, ich habe noch keine Statusbar.
Also du meinst quasi sowas hier?
Äh.
Ach nee, ach nee, Moment, das ist so ein gesamtes Ding.
Das geht nicht!
Das Funst nur...
Es...
Das fängt nur bei inaktiven an.
Und jetzt nicht mal mehr das.
Jetzt komplett broken.
Doch, jetzt scheint es wieder durch.
da ist noch irgendwie
da ist noch irgendwie ein bisschen
etwas
etwas verpackt
oder ich bin wahrscheinlich einfach zu dumm
dafür das zu benutzen
gut
dann haben wir jetzt halt keine Transparency
im Hintergrund erstmal, damit komme ich auch klar
so
das ist aber doch schon mal
prinzipiell, so wie kann man denn
Fuzzel-Theme
wie stellt man das ein
Achso hier
Wie installiert man Themes
Da kann ich auch gleich mal ein Rofi Zeug rüber kopieren
Gibt es Fussel Themes
Base 16 Tomorrow Night
Oder sowas
Gut
Das muss ich dann auch noch einstellen
Weil das passt ja hier optisch überhaupt nicht dazu
Ähm
Viel interessanter finde ich
Gibt es denn für Fussel, Fussel einen Emoji Picker?
Naja.
Anscheinend nicht.
Bimoji
Was zum Teufel ist Bimoji
Emoji Picker
Das
Die meisten Desktop Shells haben das eingebaut
Du hast recht
Das verschieben wir auf wenn wir uns Desktop Shells
Angucken
Das warten wir bis wir uns die ganzen
Verschiedenen Desktop Shells angucken
aber ist doch so schon mal ganz brauchbar
so was brauche ich denn sonst noch es packt gerade wenig rum hallo chat ich würde gern
meinen was braucht man denn sonst noch mal unabhängig ab unabhängig von der leiste und
so wir haben ja unser terminal am start wie bei dem anderen funst des tops mehrere des tops mit
Tray Bar und so brauchen wir da noch.
Wir installieren jetzt mal.
Das packt schon.
Wir installieren jetzt mal eine
Shell, okay.
DMS Shell.
DMS Shell Niri installieren wir jetzt mal.
Das ist nicht das, was ich unbedingt benutzen will.
Aber die fällt mir jetzt so aus dem Kopf gerade ein.
fixed fixed
Wie starte ich das jetzt?
DMS GitHub Neri.
Dank Material Shell.
Installation.
Ja wunderbar und wie?
DMS Run.
Ah, guck mal da, jetzt haben wir hier oben sowas.
Dynamic Theming.
das muss man bei floating einstellen
ich gebe das mal das ist eigentlich habe ich das diesen stream gar nicht vorne
aber was zum teufel mag der das kann man ist es wirklich an usable in der vm das backt total rum
Das machen wir aber nächstes Mal dann.
Wollen wir nicht jetzt.
Dann suchen wir uns hier eine ordentliche Shell-Buy raus.
Ach, hier gibt es jetzt auch einen
Launcher und sowas.
Aber ganz ehrlich, den Launcher werde ich eh nicht
verwenden. Ich werde bei dem hier bleiben. Oder wie der
Rofi installieren.
Was ist jetzt? Was habe ich jetzt gemacht?
Chat?
Was habe ich da jetzt
veranstaltet gerade.
Ach, Moment.
Mein Desktop-Hintergrund wird da übernommen.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Bam. Da muss schon ein Apepo sein.
Plugins.
Emoji. Hat das Emoji?
Hat das Emoji-Picker?
Ohne Emoji-Picker
ist das nix.
Naja, das
Das kommen wir uns das nächste Mal an
Das machen wir jetzt mal wieder aus, zack
Habt ihr das mit der Transparenz eben bei mir versucht?
Fix, okay
Hallo
Okay, das Öffnen hier von Chatlinks funktioniert anscheinend nicht.
Vielleicht bleibe ich doch einfach bei KDE, da funktioniert auf der Box alles.
Sorry.
ist der way to get the focus we know to stay transparent ja set traut mit background als
was soll ich machen traut mit background falls
Ah, Chat.
Habt ihr es gesehen?
Wir haben einen Hintergrund.
Da können wir es jetzt noch wieder auf 7 stellen.
Der Pepo, da guckt er durch.
Ja, jetzt ist es halbwegs usable.
Der Pepo
Solder champt gerade.
Sehr gut.
Okay, schau mal besser.
Hat das hier
einen Emoji Picker?
Emoji Picker Widget.
There is a Plugin.
rotieren deine backgrounds mit der zeit ja normalerweise schon hier nicht weil das fest
mit mit zwei bg gerade gesetzt ist aber aber zumindest weiß ich jetzt schon mal
wie ein background setzt wie hast du das in kde eingestellt das ist ein eigenes
skript
ihn wollte ich jetzt nicht aufmachen ich wollte mein repo aufmachen guck da ist ein
skript drin was die sachen anhand von der uhrzeit setzt und da habe ich hier
einfach ausgetauscht durch was war das plasma set background oder sowas
Ja, Leute.
Exzellent.
Damit würde ich sagen, sind wir für heute
soweit durch.
Niri ist erstmal eingerichtet, ohne
irgendwelche Bars und ohne irgendwelche
Shells und sonst was. Das machen wir die nächsten
1-2 Mal.
Aber es macht doch jetzt schon mal
zumindest einen halbwegs usable
Eindruck.
würde ich sagen.
Was habe ich eigentlich bei meinem...
Ah, das Vmware backt echt krass rum.
Was habe ich eigentlich hier bei meinem...
Gar nichts, ne?
Hier, guck mal.
Bei meinem i3
habe ich überhaupt keine
Active Window Sachen mehr.
Ja gut, aber da kann man auch nicht mehr haben.
Ja, da kann man auch nicht hier mehr haben.
Also, das werde ich erstmal beibehalten.
Niri größer Hyperland?
Keine Ahnung, ich habe Hyperland nie wirklich benutzt.
Nie wirklich benutzt?
Also, kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Chromium, lass mal noch erzählen.
Chrome.
Chromium.
Bam.
Ach so.
Ha, da fällt mir noch eine Sache ein.
Genau, Neri resized nicht, sondern skaliert horizontal und vertikal.
Guck mal hier.
Hier hast du den Overview.
Du hast verschiedene Workspaces.
Und auf den Workspaces, da skaliert es dann, wie du hier siehst.
Okay, da kann man auch drin rumschieben.
Da skaliert es dann, wie man hier sieht, horizontal.
Das heißt, du kannst beliebig viele...
...beliebig viele Fenster nebeneinander haben.
Mal gucken, wie gut ich damit klarkomme.
Ich bin da aktuell noch ein bisschen...
Ich weiß noch nicht so genau.
Animationen habe ich natürlich wie immer ausgeschaltet.
Was mich jetzt tatsächlich noch interessiert,
gibt es irgendwie die Möglichkeit,
also ich meine, hier kann man Copy-Pasten
und so, okay, oder auch nicht.
Also das Copy-Pasten
ist noch ein...
Oh fuck.
Das Copy-Pasten ist noch ein bisschen broken
manchmal.
Ja, das funzt nämlich dann
manchmal nicht.
ich drücke nämlich jetzt steuerung schiff v und dabei ist kaputt
was mich jetzt noch interessiert ist gibt es irgendwie eine möglichkeit zu copy pasten
zwischen dem host und der vm das wird wahrscheinlich nicht gescheit funktionieren
gehe ich mal von aus dass das kannst du kannst du vergessen dass das liegt aber
an vmware beziehungsweise wale and vmware interaction klappt der highlight mausrad
klick buffer du meinst du meinst du meinst du meinst das hier so
ja das scheint zu funktionieren dass man das mit scrollen markieren kann
der teufel da war er gerade im terminal
dann der neighbor of the beast gibt es diesen gag mit dem allen mädelsong
nehmen wir jetzt mal ach du meinst ob man mit dem mausrad einfügen kann moment ja das
funktioniert auch aber ich mache das ehrlich gesagt immer mit rechtsklick
ich habe das so bei western geskriptet wenn ein text markiert ist und drückt
rechte maustaste dann macht das ins clipboard wenn kein text markiert ist
und drückt rechte maustaste dann fügt das ein das heißt ich kann copy und
Paste mit der gleichen Maustaste machen.
Was war denn das gerade?
Monka.
Giga.
Ja.
Chat.
Nice Sache.
Gibt es irgendwie die Möglichkeit
VMware Workstation
Clipboard Share
Wayland. Gibt es da schon irgendwas?
Copy, Paste,
Proc, Wayland. Ja gut.
vor allem workstation 25 hat 2 u1 plus kali vor im clip ob works
m2 host but not host to vm mailen ist nicht mess mess for clipboard copy paste
dies dachte ich mir dass das nicht richtig funktioniert
Die Gnome-Leute werden den Scheiß tun, das zu implementieren.
Achso, das ist ein Custom-Projekt.
Okay, ja, da ist wieder was anderes.
Ja.
Gut, Chat, dann haben wir es für heute.
Eats.
Nächstes Mal gucken wir uns dann die unterschiedlichen Shells an, die es alles gibt.
Da gehe ich jetzt noch ein bisschen im Kreis questen oder so.
Und dann futter ich was und wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream, würde ich sagen.
reicht für heute und war ich
fünfeinhalb Stunden on.
Das ist für mich, alter Sack, schon viel zu viel.
Ich verstehe immer noch nicht, wie das Leute
schaffen, irgendwie teilweise acht, neun, zehn
Stunden am Stück zu streamen.
Komplett deadge wäre ich da
und mein ganzer Hals wäre
rot, ja, vom Reden.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Das kann ich nicht. Für mich sind fünfeinhalb Stunden
schon mehr als genug.
Alles klar, Chat.
Wir sehen uns. Bis dann. Macht's gut.
tschüss